When she goes and tells all the Muslims that the Americans hate us,
the white people hate us and they are so anti-US limits. And that, that, uh,
the Islamophobe, that the term that was invented by care. Yeah.
So we've talked about this, a bunch on the show,
but can you explain why the term specifically Islamophobia was invented and why
it's such a confusing term.
Counterpart the antisemitism?
So it's easier to say Islamophobe, so you could, okay.
If you are an Islamophobe, uh,
that's why you're with, uh,
with others that hate all the Muslims in the United States.
Well, number one, if they hated all the Muslims, um,
I've been here three decades as an adult. How come nobody hated.
Yeah.
To her district.
And I spoke to the people and I was going back and forth,
back and forth spending time there. And even sometimes on Twitter,
I would say, I'm going to be in this place from this time to come and meet me,
journalists and others.
So I had all this research about this district way
before anything else.
And then six months ago I decided to move there.
Uh, and I started thinking that
if I run, I would be the best,
the only candidate that could beat her because of my background.
I'm immune to her, uh, uh, brand of identity politics.
So I can push straight for the important issues and
important discussions.
And I'm not a shy person at all.
And I could say you are one, two, three.
Why did you meet Turkish president Erdogan before you were elected?
What promises did you, uh,
did you give him why you refuse to acknowledge the, the, uh,
Turkish ethnic cleansing against the Armenians?
Why were you outraged?
Because president Trump decided to take justice
to custom Soleimani. Why are you close to the Muslim brotherhood?
How much money have you been getting from
care through? Oh,
through care from Qatar and from the godfather of the Muslim brotherhood
I could do what no other candidates could
basically,
because if you tell her this you're a white supremacist. Yeah.
Oh yeah. You're a Thai Muslim. She cannot accuse me of that.
So you have it, I'm sure she will accuse you of it.
Yes. Because I'm not very credible because I grew
up in, uh,
probably I know more about religion than she does most likely.
Yeah. Um.
She's using religion as a shield.
She's using everything and she has this, uh,
victim cards that she throws at you. Oh, I was five.
I have PTSD. I was five years old. And,
uh, uh,
no girls should live at war because any war and everywhere
around the globe is because of the United States. So,
uh, what can you tell.
Talk a little bit about the tactics. So you mentioned this, uh,
Muslim brotherhood care connection. We mentioned,
we talked briefly before we started about Bridgette Gabriel.
Who's really been laying this thing out for years.
What the plan is to infiltrate.
You're now saying there's over a hundred candidates that are being groomed by
them. But I think one of the tactics,
which you sort of hit on is this constant desire to make everything feel crazy
all the time. And it almost seems like every time, uh,
to lead in a way where she is,
who he is almost worse than Ilhan and this way that everything she says seems to
be designed to make maximum chaos. And,
and is that really part of what they do?
That's the main thing that they do and that's how they get support.
I mean, enhan, Omar or Rashida Labe, uh, um, uh,
let me talk about each one because they have similar tactics,
but on different issues, like Ilhan Omar,
when she keeps feeding, uh, uh,
or tweeting or,
or saying the same narrative over and over and over, uh,
that I represent every Muslim, uh,
in the country first, she supposed to represent the fifth district.
She's supposed to serve the,
the fifth district and she's done zero nada,
nothing.
So when she goes and tells all the Muslims that the Americans hate us,
the white people hate us and they are so anti-Islamic. And that, that, uh,
the Islamophobe, that, the term that was invented by care. Yeah.
So.
Well, we've talked about this, a bunch on the show,
but can you explain why the term specifically Islamophobia was invented and why
it's such a confusing term.
Counterpart the antisemitism?
So it's easier to say Islamophobe so you could, okay.
If you are an Islamophobe, uh,
that's why you're with, uh,
with others that hate all the Muslims in the United States.
Well, number one, if they hated all the Muslims, um,
I've been here three decades as an adult. How come nobody hated me?
Well, I'm sure they hate me.
People probably hate you for your ideas. Now,
Ilhan is probably not thrilled with you.
Um, I doubt that, but, uh,
even after nine 11, like nine 12,
I w I've never felt threatened because I was a Muslim. I'm an American,
regardless of all these, I don't use this. And the problem is,
or I'm forced to use a Muslim from a refugee immigrants just
to, uh, uh, the identity politics that she uses.
And I stated it once on Twitter,
that was picked up by everybody, because she said,
I am a hijab, which is,
that is not the right hijab that she claims to. And I've spoken to,
uh, several, uh, uh,
American Somalis that this is not the Muslim hijab. I mean,
she wears the hijab regard, uh, based on the people that she's meeting,
she's meeting Muslim, she would cover, but hijab as an hijab,
you cannot show your chest. You cannot show your hands. It's it's,
it's all it's. It was limbs. Know that.
Right.
Well also plenty of the policies that she's for would not be policies that if
you were a strict Muslim, you would be for help. Abortion is a right.
Yes. Sorry. Abortion is healthcare.
And it's human rights as well. So, uh,
but the problem with the people in the district that they don't follow
what she does, uh, MDC on a daily basis.
They don't know that she missed half, uh,
half of the votes that anyone else in the house,
she doesn't vote for the district. You know, when she votes,
when it comes to foreign policies, that's when her votes.
And can you believe that she voted against sending,
uh, AIDS to, to so much some money.
And then she went outside 10 minutes later giving a press conference
saying, Oh, we did it.
I mean, this woman is filled with lies. And again,
her worst, um, uh,
mistake that she didn't give me the interview,
that what made me go back and forth in that,
what made me decide that I am going to cross the line
between being a journalist to a, a politician.
So what are some of the other tactics that they use besides the just general
there they want to cause chaos all the time and seem to always everything they
say seems to be designed to deepen that divide. What else,
what else are they doing?
Handouts that it, on reality does work.
How could you give free healthcare to everybody?
It doesn't work this way. I mean, what would they get the money from?
How could you forgive all the student loans?
What would they do for people that already paid their loans?
Yeah. We're not getting anything back or know.
How, I mean all these handouts and like free this and free this I'm,
everybody's going to have a free house and it's going to have a friend. I mean,
this is ridiculous. We are not in China. And even in China,
uh, they don't do that.
So,
but can you explain a little bit more how the Islamists and care and Mo and the
Muslim brotherhood, how they use the Progressive's like, it's like,
cause this is what I think a lot of people,
a lot of people see this match made in hell.
You're supposed to be PR for progressive,
but all these other values are completely anti progressive,
but I don't think people really understand how this thing fully ties together.
The progressive don't have minds, their right minds,
the Muslim brotherhood is using the far left and the
progressive for their own, uh, adjectives.
They're not doing it for the sake of the far left or the sake
of progressive. No, they are using them big time.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.